قالت وزاره الدفاع التايوانيه بانها ارسلت
مقاتلات جويه بعدما عبرت عشر طائرات حربيه
صينيه من طرازات مختلفه لخط الوسط
الافتراضي لمضيق الجزيره واضافت الوزاره
التايوانيه ايضا بان اربع سفن حربيه صينيه
قامت بدوريات قتاليه واكدت بانها ارسلت
طائرات مقاتله ونشرت سفنا وانظمه صواريخ
بريه لمراقبه الوضع مكرره صياغه تستخدمها
عاده عندما تشرح طريقه ردها على الانشطه
العسكريه الصناع وهذه هي المره الثانيه في
اقل من اسبوع التي تعلن فيها تايوان رصد
انشطه عسكريه لبكين بعدما حلقت 37 طائره
عسكريه صينيه الخميس الماضي في نطاق منطقه
الدفاع الجوي للجزيره لمتابعه المزيد من
الاخبار والبرامج والقصص الانسانيه
والوثائقيات والتقارير الاخباريه لا تنسوا
الاشتراك في قناتنا على يوتيوب الضغط على
زر الاعجاب وتفعيل جرس التنبيهات